hi i'm megan fox and they are gonna  force me to watch all of my old  interviews  i just got sick to my stomach oh  i do remember this oh this is your first  big family it is thank you so much no  please don't make me listen to myself  what am i talking about uh what am i  wearing what is that necklace look at my  hair and makeup that's so bad  just keep smiling and don't let what  people say get you down i still talk  like that which is the scary thing i  don't sound more mature or womanly at  all look at my eyebrows what in jesus  name where were my eyebrows how long is  this gonna go on oh kill me just kill me  why are you doing this to me just  smother me or something